this is a story about people it's about
the first VidCon to take place in Europe
it's a story that could be about
traveling to apps the dam with its
two-wheeled way of life and beautiful
canals or about videos or about famous
youtubers but to me it's a story about
people thousands of us gathered together
this weekend united by an idea the idea
of community irrespective of what they
were interested in people felt they
belonged to a global family that laughed
cried and learns together all through
videos they watched on the Internet
through YouTube I've been a part of this
community for over ten years growing up
watching channels on YouTube grow from
people with cameras in their bedrooms to
huge global enterprises with Titanic
social media stars it's been an
ever-present important part of my life a
source of entertainment information and
escape it was actually through YouTube
that I met my housemate and friends Dan
and it was with Dan that I traveled to
Amsterdam
we spent the two full days at the
convention meeting with like-minded fans
of channels engaging in inflatable
warfare and going to panels and shows
one thing that's always existed in media
of all kinds is the divide between
people that create and people that
consume Hollywood stars are idolized and
viewed as separates from the public in
the same way that classical composers
and authors were but YouTube is
different to me YouTube has always been
the platform that truly democratized
media creation anyone with access to a
camera which means anyone with access to
a smartphone so basically anyone can
upload content that can be seen by
anyone in the world there are no
barriers to distribution if what you
make is entertaining or educational or
just plain good people will watch it and
what people choose to make is often a
reflection of who they are people like
Charlie McDonald and the green brothers
and Hannah ha uploaded videos to YouTube
of them being themselves talking about
what they found interesting and
important and doing so in a way that
people found engaging YouTube was a way
of taking the interesting passionate
engaging people of the world and making
them accessible to everyone like letting
that kid that everyone hopes they can
sit next to in class sit next to
everyone at once the divide between
video creator and consumer was eroded by
the fact that anyone can and often does
create content while consuming that made
by
others but also by the fact that the
very reason someone becomes well known
on the platform is because they're
engaging and relatable to their audience
but by virtue of being popular a divide
does get thrown up there's a distinction
made between us the viewing audience and
them those making the most popular
content it's inevitable when a platform
becomes as popular as YouTube not
everyone has millions of people watching
what they make
but at events like VidCon this gets
reinforced by panels that have huge
audiences sat in seats and a select few
people on the stage the panels and
sessions that we went to were a variety
of genres and sizes from an amazing
workshop on how to edit a scishow
episode to panel on science featuring my
friends Sally and Chinni and a huge
shows that have the entire convention in
the audience all of these were amazing
and it was a weird cognitive dissonance
to see people that you used to see on a
laptop in real life now for the past
seven years I've also been creating
videos and I've had some moderate
success with it and because of this
together with the generosity of my
friend Sally LePage Thank You Sally I
got to spend a large part of VidCon
hanging out with those youtubers invited
to give talks at the conference
backstage I was a little bit
trepidatious about this to be honest
they say you should never meet your
heroes and I was worried I might meet
some of the people who've been a big
part of my YouTube life for so long and
they turn out to be massive douches with
huge egos
but I really shouldn't have worried
because every youtuber that I hang out
with and I was lucky to meet a lot of
them was super lovely charming and
generally a normal person they were just
people with a passion for something be
that science entertaining music or
whatever the whole reason they became
famous on the platform was because they
were relatable people without an ego the
kind of person you just want to hang out
with which reminded me of someone well
several people these guys the audience
the rest of us all the people I chatted
to VidCon and I was lucky to chat to a
lot of them was super lovely they were
people with a passion for something he
felt part of a community and came to
VidCon to celebrate that and to meet
their favorite creators the people I met
on the convention floor some of whom I'm
lucky enough to have watched my videos
were just the same as the people I met
backstage VidCon did several things for
me that I'd like to thank Hank and John
for firstly I got a kick-ass new profile
picture so thanks for that guys but
VidCon showed me that there really is no
difference between the people that make
some of the most popular video content
in the world and the people that watch
it that passion that geekiness that
friendliness is common to everyone in
the community regardless of how popular
what they make is and concurrently
there's no barrier to becoming one of
those creators in a service like YouTube
even in the crowded marketplace that we
have today if you make good stuff in a
genuine engaging way people will watch
any barriers to that are ones that you
create for yourself VidCon was an
incredibly affirming experience it
reinforced my belief that YouTube has
changed the way that media interacts
with our lives and how meritocratic
media has become it gave me fresh
motivation for making my own content and
new perspective on the people that I
watch so thank you Hank and John but
also thank you for something else
because on top of all the new
perspective and the creators I met and
the new friends I made VidCon gave me a
fantastic weekend with one of my best
mates all made possible through you and
through YouTube said cheers guys